hello guys Ryan Wright Danny D baby ten
celebrities who dated underage girls of
course we're gonna watch this one that
guy all right let's see if these are
real celebrities yo yo leopard D Stevie
young girls in this world buying young
girls done if you're a superstar r kelly
is known for his soulful voice and
amazing musical talent but he's also
known for being a pedophile
sometimes that clearly showed Kelly
having sex with and urinating into the
mouth of a 15 year old girl he was
acquitted of all charges but what's even
more astonishing was his relationship
with the late R&B princess Aaliyah when
he was 27 and she was barely out of the
8th grade
the to illegally eloped the marriage was
annulled by her parents in 1995 as alia
was persuaded to lie about her age on
the certificate Joel Madden and Disney
star Hilary Duff when she was only 16 at
the time Wow was 25 years old
the relationship was kept under wraps
husband acquaint the guy cosmopolitan
appealing she revealed that she lost her
virginity to Joel when she was underage
when asked about it she said I had a
26-year old boyfriend
so everyone can make their own
assumptions about what I was doing suck
in the gap Wilmer Valderrama was one of
the breakout stars on a hit TV series
that 70 and the 2007 MTV show yo mama
apparently Wilmer likes to get involved
with young Hollywood starlets his first
underage hookup was with Mandy Moore
at the time she was 16 and he was 20 in
2006 he did an interview on the Howard
Stern Show where he admitted to taking
her virginity when Wilbur turned 24 was
barely 17 then at the age of 30 he began
a long standing relationship with pop
star Demi Lovato the two started dating
in early 2010 when she was only 17 she
was a singer Jerry Seinfeld maybe one of
the funniest comedians of our time with
the success of his hit TV show in his
flourishing stand-up career he was once
considered one of comedies most eligible
bachelors so what made him want to date
a young schoolgirl in the early 90s at
age 38 he dated 17-year old high school
seniors Shoshana lahnstein to this day
he claims that he fell in love with her
and they dated for four years their
romantic relationship ended Wow she
didn't want to deal with all the
publicity any more [ __ ] there's more
though then Fast & Furious star Paul
Walker tragically died in a fatal car
crash when he was 40 years old he will
be missed by people around the world
especially by his fiancee Jasmine
Gosnell jasmine was only 16 years old
when she started dating Walker who was
33 at the time their passionate love
affair lasted up until his untimely
death in 2013 they were even living
together in his Los Angeles home an
insider stated in an interview that he
knew she was young but he always said
she was worth the wait
[Music]
Natalya professional basketball player
Karl Malone is considered the greatest
power forward to ever play the game but
the two-time NBA MVP award winner got a
couple of women pregnant in the early
80s at the beginning of his career one
woman in particular was Gloria Bell
shockingly when Malone was 20 he
impregnated Bell when she was only 13
although it has been proven in court
that he is indeed the father he refuses
to acknowledge paternity of his son de
mettre spell after the Metris graduation
the two had their first and only
conversation where Malone stated it was
too late for them to have a father-son
relationship
dimitra's Bell has recently made
as a defensive tackle in the nfie the
Buffalo Bills via Eagles and Dallas
Cowboys the king of rock and roll Elvis
Presley was at the pinnacle of his
career in the 1950s his sound swagger
and sexuality sparked controversy but
who was adored by millions of screaming
fans around the world one of those fans
would be 14 year old Priscilla when the
to admit the celebri calls him saying
that she was just a baby Elvis was 24 at
the time she eventually moved into
Graceland with him while she finished
high school
she married Elvis in Las Vegas at the
age of 21 and nine months later their
daughter Lisa Marie was born lot of
information was informational hence
information that narrator sometimes you
made me feel like he was raping me he's
a pedophile yeah like nine years they
were like Paul Walker passed at this
untimely death but unfortunately for his
yeah you remember Aurra Kelly pissing in
that girl's mouth no that was like a
huge ordeal like they were like so many
people talking about it all the time
that's their skits and stuff oh my god
that is so funny I want to see it yeah
dude I've never I've never seen a
pissing video in my life it's like a
category online it's a ten yell no have
you done that
no would you ever yeah yeah not the
person I thought you were piano yeah I
know P is no there's baby if it was like
John Goodman you let John Goodman pee on
you yeah it depends on like who it is
like John Goodman Will Smith
I let Ryan Gosling pee on me Chris Pine
I don't know it depends out dominated I
want a feat like help hug you know I
mean everyone do like as a game
can you get in Danielle everybody
Danielle really funny okay so if you had
to marry one kill one or [ __ ] one of
these people who would it be the
celebrities yeah out of all these
they're mainly guys know they have girl
counterparts I would marry the the team
that Jerry Seinfeld was with okay let's
see no not her
oh I probably wait what is it wait I
don't forget I want to say mine okay so
I would I would marry um oh Hansie -
Audra I'd [ __ ] Chris Pine and I would
kill Frank Sinatra earn Elvis and marry
Elvis with Chris Pine you mean Chad
Michael Murray no Chris Pine is not in
this video
Oh Walker marry Elvis has exes Paul
Walker and kill Seinfeld you would kill
Seinfeld yeah his face makes me want to
punch it
I mean they're all the underage they're
not underage anymore so it's okay Mandy
Moore marry Mandy Moore Wow that's okay
I would and what are the other choices I
mean no what are the other know what are
the other categories that I have to do
Oh marry kill sex I would kill
I would kill Karl Malone II just sounds
like a douchebag okay definitely kill
caramel I'm just totally not even like
oh there's no my cute sex
[ __ ] let's see here let's see I Hilary
Duff maybe no sad voice
I'm sorry Daniel Wilmer Valderrama
though he's the most consistent when it
comes to dating the younger ones do you
think he's attractive yeah so he is like
I don't know I was samus Fez
so really you think so really
feds from that 70 ship yeah we're
talking about the same vets yeah he's
really hot wow what is it about him that
you like I mean what is bad about him
he's your future good-looking yeah I
know but he's kind of like all these
like pours and [ __ ] I mean we all have
pores I know I mean there's a lot that's
fretful I know but as a celebrity you're
expected to be better
what he's so hot especially when he was
beanie
how's this beanie make me look stupid
hot thanks but no when it comes to call
him alone the fact that his kid wasn't
like he didn't let it determine his
career and yeah I'm gonna get back at
you by being successful yeah he became
so successful Frank Sinatra says revenge
it's the best form of success and it
frankerz of Elvis it was Frank who said
it okay and Elvis Presley you know like
it kind of makes sense that you would
wind up with a young girl yeah he was
like surrounded by young girls all the
time
seriously he was a heartthrob and at
that time is the 50s and shares it's a
different time it really is like sex
drugs and rock and roll and they had a
kid becoming a good singer I once met
Joel and Nicole Richie a vicious dogs
were that's how I met Danielle I used to
cook at a restaurant called vicious dogs
Hollywood what time Nicole Richie came
in fortunately and her Joel were there
and she had her baby and so has I Love
New York yes but a holdover time I'm
Richard I know Joel in order to get a
conversation going with them there was a
there's a baby next door who I would
sometimes babysit and fortunately she
was there so I grabbed her and played
with her a lot I gave the baby I was
holding a lot of love
and it's the coal Richie brought her
baby over and was like let's have them
meet no do not have it so happen which
is like you know what my baby could be
this random baby like yeah babies do
that oh you got a baby - is that like it
was my kid this sounds like a
fabrication no it really happened proper
that one maybe I want to get vicious dog
she didn't live in vicious dogs or
something
you didn't present a baby and she was
like this you know
no no it's Danielle it's so work she was
holding her baby and I was holding a
baby - so we didn't like switch no no
well anyway Joel you're a good dad
and you got a hot wife she's still hot
yeah really
she's fine she's a s I don't know buddy
you know celebrity years she could be
like old gotta be aware that [ __ ] Dan
you know anyway guys listen if you're
new to the channel subscribe to the real
rejects it might be worth your time who
knows danielle has an Instagram where
she does local photos obviously on
Instagram lefty this faith all the time
it's like look look at her oh my god
she's so adorable so pretty to be on
Instagram